all right there we go Wow okay I'm
getting teary eyes you drive through
almost as if you're going through a
McDonald's or Starbucks I'm supposed to
fill out this questionnaire so that the
health officials ahead of us can
identify whether or not I'm gonna need
some testing they are taking my
temperature from both ears actually
they've just shown me that my body
temperature is 36.6 degrees Celsius it's
very ticklish and it was a bit abrupt in
a day or two I will probably receive my
results I will probably get them through
a text messages South Korea has seen
cases rise more than two hundred fold in
just a few weeks and a lot of that could
be because testing is so widespread here
the government has set up more than 500
coronavirus testing sites processing
more than 210 thousand people in a few
weeks some critics say that if the
government had early on closed its
border with China and restricted travel
from the epicenter of the country's
epidemic then maybe it wouldn't have
needed to create so many testing sites
like this drive-through
[Music]
that kovat 19 can be characterized as a
pandemic
the biggest takeaway is that the drive
through testing site is quick efficient
and minimizes the risk that potential
patients might get the virus from those
who already have it the biggest
limitation though is you must be able to
drive and have access to a car to use
this facility this probably means people
who can't drive or people with
disabilities will face difficulty in
coming here and undertaking the tests
[Music]